welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz i'm your
host and today i'm
really excited to be joined by josh
white and i've done an introduction
already so we're going to get straight
into it and josh i want to ask you the
million dollar question
uh to start with which is and i'm sure
you've thought a lot about it since
you've been growing your team
but i really want to hear your take on
like what characteristics and traits do
you believe make up a highly successful
recruiter in in today's market let's
let's start there
yeah love it
so for me
i think i think there's i think there's
a hundred sort of interchangeable things
right that like one person has that one
person doesn't have because everyone's
you know uh authentic version of
themselves but
what what it comes down to especially in
the early days is
someone who has a a growth mindset
before anything else
someone who is people or customer
focused
and
someone who is who is
really at their core very coachable
i think for you to go from knowing
nothing about recruitment to being a
recruitment superstar
those those three things will really get
you there
i love that i feel great i love those i
love those points growth mindset
coachability
and then the other one was like being
like really passionate about customer
service did you say yeah it's it's
people focus or customer focus it's
about
when you're talking someone that you're
actually listening to them when you're
talking someone
you
are taking in what they say
and making them feel heard um and that
you're actually putting them first right
so you know there's loads of little
things that go into that integrity
um
they're critical to relationship
building which is what we're all trying
to do
love it
so today i know what people are really
excited about and obviously this is what
i've been speaking about right i think
there's a real trend
of uk recruitment firms going to the us
they want it all they want to take over
america right
so we are going to talk about your
entire journey but obviously today we're
going to really hone in on like what has
josh's journey been like over the last
three or so years in
taking your life
your career to
uh chicago and to the states so i guess
just before we go into that
where i always like to start obviously
you've worked at stanton house for over
five years you've progressed your
recruitment career you've got a track
record there like who who was josh
before recruitment
you know what it's really i've been
thinking about this a lot actually not
only because you asked me about it um
but because it's because it's um because
it's mental health uh awareness week
month i actually think i was a bit of a
lonely soul i think um you know i'm
anyone who knew me when i was at school
you know anywhere from sort of 14 to 16
i used to walk around the place telling
everyone that i wanted to be a
millionaire which was
really yeah quite frankly a little bit
ludicrous like i always have my little
entrepreneurial moments you know selling
headphones you know i was always talking
about big projects and big things i
wanted to do but i never really i never
really like clicked into gear and when
it comes to going to a sick form college
i got about three weeks in though i was
like this ain't for me i'm gonna go work
full time and my first job was selling
suitcases in a house of fraser
which i
actually did for about a year or so
and then i then i got into furniture
sales i started selling high-end
furniture
but that that whole sort of
you know
retail thing just it just weren't for me
like i think i enjoyed it because i was
quite passionate about and i got
passionate about suitcases right but for
me
i really wanted to be in control of my
own destiny and when someone told me
about recruitment i saw that as an
opportunity to you know be in control of
my own destiny right rather than waiting
for people to come in and buy something
i could go out there and get them to
come to me
i love that
yes like i i had no idea what i wanted
to do
i mean i even i even did
a plumbing course at college but the
only reason why i did that right was i
don't know how old you are but was you
around when you got ema for college i
remember that
i don't well i didn't really i made it
into week three of college
ema was basically for attending college
you got 30 quid a week
wow
back then that was a that was an xbox
game yeah yeah yeah
but yeah so but like i had i had no idea
what to do but it seems like you had a
similar thing where like set when i sort
of stumbled into sales
that's like i i couldn't resin that
really resonates me like i know you
didn't quite have it from yeah you're
right relying on people walking into the
shop but i'm assuming what did resonate
with you about it was like josh couldn't
show up to work suitcases financial
whatever but like you know if you work
harder than the person next you like you
will get rewarded for that and that
that's that's when when i stumbled
across sales i was like oh my yeah that
this is exactly what i want to do
yeah i think i felt quite lonely until i
found sales like
i was it wasn't that i wasn't
necessarily academic i definitely didn't
apply myself i'm sure we've all heard
that before but when i found sales i was
like hold on like i can earn i can earn
money just by by chatting to people and
helping them helping them find something
right like helping them buy something
this is amazing
yeah no but i kind of i mean
my first sales job wasn't selling
furniture we're selling barcrawl tickets
in magaluf commission only
wow so a bit more exciting than
suitcases well at least try to make it
sound exciting anyway
um more action
oh absolutely well um
so what i guess what i always like to
ask as well so i love you sharing that
what what has a career recruitment
giving you then that maybe you least
expected
um
you know what
i think it's given me the the ability to
to to learn and be challenged every day
that that is a little bit philosophical
um a practical answer would be you know
it's definitely helped me out it's given
me you know a lot of financial stability
and security and that's amazing but i
think the philosophical piece is
definitely around sort of being able to
learn grow be challenged every single
day i i think it's i think when you and
i see this with people that come you
know that come through the ranks at
stanton house and and i was probably
exactly the same you kind of think okay
i'll do this training thing and then you
know a couple of months in i've got it
right
i you know training mothers are off i
know how to do it and i mean it's a bit
of rude awakening when you realize that
actually the learning curve is
completely continuous
i love that
so just giving you yeah no i think
that's great so just continue to
challenge yourself obviously giving you
the financial stability
uh but yeah it's obviously ended up
giving you a lot more in terms of like
just being able to control your own
destiny from a sales standpoint exactly
i mean it's also moved me out to estates
and i met my amazing fiance so i've got
to be very grateful for those things too
but um yeah
absolutely okay cool so i guess final
question on the early days and then
we'll we'll get into the the america
stuff which i know everyone wants to
to learn about
just obviously yeah quite common
question but i think sometimes it brings
out interesting questions i i'm sure you
can agree but like there's probably
never been
more young people entering the
recruitment industry than ever has been
before with this sort of recruitment
boom the amount of vacancies the amount
of jobs that uh new people can get
working on right away like know it
knowing what you know now what advice
would you give to josh starting out in
in recruitment and starting his career
again do you think
i would say
i would say prepare to prepare to work
prepare to be humbled
and prepared to work with intensity
and focus and discipline
i think especially
you know having having worked before and
perhaps this would have been different
if i come straight from university
having worked before i had a bit of a
baseline of like right what's it like to
turn up to work every day and
recruitment was
certainly from my perspective
significantly harder than anything i've
done before
um and i was you know very humbled in
the early days by you know by trying new
things and failing at them um you've got
to prepare to be failed to prepare to
fail
and
not let it not let it throw you off like
stay focused with it
yeah
yeah it's tough at the beginning
yeah how long did it take to do your
first deal
remember longer probably longer than it
should have i reckon it was i reckon it
was uh four or five months it was a it
was a part-time
uh part-time
contractor or interim who was like a uh
you know non-qual uh financial
controller
you always remember it don't you yeah
you don't you can't you can't can't
forget it yeah like mine was decent it
wasn't it was an old colleague
it was he sorted me out that's good that
was very memorable
mine was pretty scrappy
i love it
so select so obviously just to give
people context obviously worked in the
uk
for a number of years
uh and then
obviously within the finance space you
just mentioned then sort of a finance
finance professional yeah but obviously
from what i can see on linkedin
you can help me out with the timeline
but obviously 2019
is that when you went to the states or
were you already working and building
like because you hear a lot of people
right they try and get traction before
they go over there so from what i can
see online from october 2019
it says senior consultant cyber security
sales in chicago yeah when did this
start yeah october 2019.
so
so you didn't do so you didn't do any
like building
talking to people before you went there
no we didn't at all actually um i mean
my my colleague my colleague james um
james warren potentially did like a
little bit um but i mean
how much how much did that have an
impact i mean it was a couple of months
i think if i think you know i know lots
of i know lots of people that do do that
model where they kind of like incubate
the business in the uk and then and then
you know take it over and they've
already got a few clients and so on and
so forth and i think if we had if we'd
done that maybe that would have been a
good thing but to be honest i literally
i rocked up at chicago in chicago i went
to went to meet the team
um
you know which was which was two people
who were already there two people
yeah i was the last i was the last
person to arrive i mean they all arrived
about a week before me um went to meet
them both and uh then the next day
rocked up and like i was like right what
is what is this new market i'm doing
wow so so just a frame rate for people
because this is important so
you was doing it with two other people
yeah was there a similar level for as
you experience wise yeah so you had
you've got uh henry yeomans who's uh vp
of north america so henry's uh yeah a
few few more years experience and than
me he's been with stanton house bit
longer and so he joined to sort of run
the whole thing and then you have myself
and a guy called james who were pretty
much yeah same level
same level okay cool so then like so you
said they got there a couple of weeks
before you but so like did that did
stanton house have a presence in the u.s
at all like just so we understand that
right okay so right let's break this
down then because that's that's nuts
right so
what why so obviously you said there
this market this new market i'm doing
just talk to us a bit about cyber
security and why that ended up being the
market that you wanted to focus on
because that would be helpful for people
so when we when we set the business up
in in north america we wanted to have a
really niche focus we all know you know
inch inch wide mile deep um is the way
to go and we decided to we we landed on
cyber security we thought right that's
going to be the the right market for us
to go into um so we sort of split it up
we said right james is going to you know
do the sort of technical cyberpiece um
and josh is gonna do pre-sales
which at the time we didn't really know
what that meant um but so today what
that looks like is we've got a team that
recruit for um the recruit for corporate
america right so they place technical
cyber security folk to help protect and
defend uh corporate businesses in the
states and then we've got my lot which
has expanded slightly outside of cyber
now but what we do is we predominantly
place sales marketing and customer
success people into cyber security
startups
okay and that you so have you how long
have you done that for then that whole
time yeah that yeah yeah i mean i've
been doing that since october october
2019 now uh okay
so yeah it was i mean it was fascinating
on day one trying to work out what it
was i remember i moved out there and the
first thing i did was change my linkedin
sales in chicago and i put cyber
pre-sales like i didn't even really know
what it meant to be honest and i'm happy
to admit that and so yeah
you know i mean it's amazing building
out built that market
yeah well okay cool i'm excited to get
into this so
just the last bit of context for people
then so that's what it looked like when
you were there what does it look like
today
in terms of team
what you did last year or whatever like
let's just get that out of the way as
well for people yeah so last year we i
mean we started 2021 with three of us
um the same three because we didn't we
didn't grow much in in 2020 for obvious
reasons um
and today we are coming up to 18 people
oh wow
um so last night what you're trying to
do on track is it what's your financial
year is it january to december or yeah
yeah so
um i mean we are
we are on track as an office to do
well over
i mean we're our target for the years
3.5 as an office
um yeah and already
i mean you know both both teams did over
200 in quarter one yeah on
that target our first sort of two teams
worth doing you know a million dollars
each which is a good start to the year
when you're you know when each team's
target is one point seven five
one point seven years mega so what did
you just quickly then final bit what
what what did you um
end on last year then billings wise
personally yeah me personally i ended up
on somewhere
somewhere between six and
somewhere between six and seven hundred
yeah okay nice so let let's break this
down
so
i guess the first thing that i have to
ask you because i think it's it's really
normal for people and it could be
helpful for people that are are going
into this data but just really quickly
like
because i'm sure you help people with
this now what are the what what's the
advice or what are the principles to
like upskilling yourself in the in the
new market that you're in i think a lot
of people can overthink this be worried
about it so knowing what you know now
these things like if i rock into all
chicago with his tomorrow and i'm like
[ __ ] all about cyber security what are
you telling me to do that can help me
get there quicker so then i'm i don't
feel really unconfident speaking to
people i don't feel like they're better
than me because i don't have the
information or knowledge like just talk
to me a bit about that quickly because i
think people can that's helpful for
people
yeah
so
i think
i think the market the market itself in
terms of recruitment right recruitment
recruitment so whether you're doing
recruitment in the uk or you're doing
recruitment in the us fundamentally like
in my opinion the the sort of the the
principles of the things that you need
to do to be successful are are the same
now there are there are naturally
nuances um so nuances would be you know
you're not gonna you're not gonna work a
job with a client unless you've signed a
contract with them
because contract law in the u.s is
everything so we measure success when
we're not doing you know when we're not
doing deals with how many clients are we
signing up
right it is a and that's because if they
haven't got a contract signed they don't
have to pay you that's what you said
yeah basically yeah yeah basically um so
you know we measure our success you know
it's a leading indicator for us as to
whether or not we're winning
um
you know there are there are all sorts
of things i mean we don't we don't we're
we're a completely perm business at
stanton house um
i don't know i can't really offer much
opinion on the on the contract business
i'd probably say it looks scary scary uh
complicated but we're not we're not in a
position
maybe i didn't i wasn't clear so like
what was what i wanted to get your
advice on was for anyone listening that
like is going into like a brand new
market that they don't know much about
because you know you said like you
didn't have a clue about cyber security
i was just curious
like
what
how how can what's your advice to people
to like upskill themselves in their
niche
that's been helpful yeah okay so for me
um i think you know if you're a podcast
person listen to podcasts right you can
always find podcasts on your i mean if
you listen to this you're a podcast
person right you can always find a
podcast on your on your specialism on
your market
go and go and go and listen to it right
like try and absorb some of that
information
but i think the the biggest thing and
the the thing that you need to do before
you do anything else is just go and talk
some candidates
and i was pretty open with a lot of
people like i said to people look i'm
i'm a recruiter i just moved here from
the uk
um i've just started this new market i'd
love to i'd love to love to have a chat
with you and just understand a bit about
you know ask you a couple of questions
about the market
the the best way to learn
is is getting on the phone in my opinion
you can do all the reading you want
um and i used to be a big procrastinator
you
right
my my first boss kevin culverhouse
openly
told our entire company once that he
watched me read a uh a ftse 100 annual
report before i tried to call call
someone
so i
and it doesn't help right i mean it's
not a good use of time so for me i think
the best thing to do is like be
vulnerable be open to learning and just
be honest with people
there will there will come a point where
you know you need to
you know not fake it till you make it
but you know you need to start
you know you ask questions in the right
way right so we we teach people how to
how to have a good first conversation
with someone without having to know
everything about the market and by them
saying hey you know tell me tell me a
bit about what your biggest challenge is
day to day
that that person who asked that question
learned something not only about the
candidate but about their industry
no thanks for sharing that so let's
break this down then so like it sounds
like obviously you went you told us what
you ended up in last year which is
pretty much your whole
first year right and obviously that was
during covert vibes as well
so like
what
did you have a plan then
at all well i got out there
yeah because like you said you finished
nearly north of like 700 k in that 2020.
so that's like october 2019 you land
oh sorry yeah i always get confused at
years like it's it's a crazy
okay so
let's break this down then so basically
talk to us about
people like talk to us a bit about that
first year then firstly before we then
go into the last two that first year did
you have a plan how long did it take to
get traction
let's just talk a bit about that as to
what it looked like from what you
experienced it took it took a couple of
months to start to start getting
traction um
you know my my strategy was about
meeting senior people
and making friends with them my strategy
was about uh specking
um and my strategy was about you know
just meeting and talking to as many
people generally as i could
um
so i did a lot of that in the in the
sort of first few months i started to
get some really good traction probably
december january
i was um i did my i think i did my first
i did my first two deals in the us um
in sort of january february of 2020.
okay yeah it's like two to four months
yeah yeah about that so that was pretty
that was pretty pretty lucky we um we
actually you know we had this massive
gong we had a we had a budget to buy
furniture for the office and it was it
was a sign to me and i said it was five
hundred dollars and i spent 95 of it on
the biggest gong you've ever seen
[Laughter]
we were all so excited and i mean look
the day that chicago went into lockdown
march 16th my birthday i had i had like
three or four offers pulled i mean it
was devastating like i i just
i've moved my life over here i've been
building out this market for five months
i'm about to do some you know amazing
couple of deals like way quicker than i
thought and now suddenly this has
happened like what what did i do
um
and that that year was rough but do you
know what
it was a great opportunity to build
great relationships with great people
because i literally like i had no jobs
to work right
so
i was proactively reaching out to senior
people and making a making a ton of
friends
right i was meeting them putting them
through putting them through a sort of
full full uh sort of interview giving
them feedback adding loads of value
keeping in touch with them like i've
built some amazing relationships and the
relationships i've built
in 2020 are the ones that enabled me
to come to from a show now yeah
you know i had one quarter last year
where i build
about 450k which is i mean way more than
i ever thought i would do in one quarter
right it's possible yeah yeah and
every single one of those deals you can
track
to those relationships built in 2020.
so
relationships
then
is that important in the american market
yeah i think so
um
i mean this with
it's different it's definitely different
so
my perspective on this
having worked the u.s market and the uk
market
in the uk it's really really hard to
even like get a seat at the table
sometimes with a with with a senior
stakeholder
like i remember you know spending
12 months trying to get hold of a of a
cfo like it was it was an absolute grind
to like get
you know get sat round the table with
them but once you did you know you had
something that you could really trust in
in the us
i find that you know people are people
are nicer to a degree right like they're
people in the us people are you know
sales is a is a uh
is a more prestigious career than it is
in the uk people are less skeptical of
sales people
and what that means is it's quite it's
quite easy to get a seat round the table
with someone
it's easy to get a you know to get a
sort of engaged customer as such or
someone who you think wants to work with
you what's really hard
is getting that you know that loyal
status getting a customer who sort of um
you know what won't pick up the phone to
anyone else but you
that that takes that takes a long time
what are the principles to get into that
point
i think the principles to get into that
point
for me
are about
talking to someone
not because you've got something
not because you need something
but just because you care about that
person
i have i have so many customers now
you know
i mean so many i mean you can only have
so many relationships that are this
strong but i've probably got
20 20 relationships with people that i
would genuinely say are almost you know
professional friends right i know i know
their kids names i know i know what they
like to do at the weekends
that stuff takes a lot of time to get
there you've got a you've got to add
value to them professionally you've got
to show an interest in who they are
both professionally and personally
and you've got you've got to keep in
touch with them
how can how can recruiters listen to
this add value to because i'm sure
everyone listens to this wants to have
those types of relationships well you'd
like to think so
yeah but like how how can recruiters
listen to this josh like
when you say add value i i understand
that no i have some ideas that come up
for me but like just to go a bit
granular here like what does that value
actually look like beyond talking to
them about jobs or candidates
yeah so
every senior person i meet
every person i meet i try and give them
feedback there is there is feedback you
can give absolutely everyone and
feedback's a gift
but it's something that
a lot of the time
we feel a bit uncomfortable about giving
so yeah i'll meet someone i'll say
are you open some feedback yeah that's
quite a critical part because someone
has to acknowledge that they are happy
to receive it
most of the time people say yeah sure
i'll always find something to give to
them i say right you know i really
enjoyed meeting you here's what i think
you know you did really well
here's a here's a couple of things and
i'll you know give some examples here
are a couple of things i think you know
if you tweet you get a better outcome
and i'll give an example i'll say right
you said this
and if you said this
you would have you know people would
perceive it much better right
so i'm giving someone something which is
you know could be life-changing for them
because at their you know next interview
whether it's through through you know
josh or or not
if they bring a technique or or or if
they utilize some feedback
that came from me
you know they're they're they'll
remember that
what does that look like for clients
that is that's really fascinating i've
got a great story to tell you about that
i had a customer
a client
who
was introduced to me and he said he said
right so i'm sick of recruiters telling
me they're different like what really
what makes you different
and yeah i'm talking about customer
experience and all the stuff that i
really believe in
and he he basically he's pretty direct
he said josh said i'm not buying it
i've heard it before he said that he
said i'm not buying a job i'm not buying
it
he said what makes you really different
and i said
our interview process
when we meet candidates and we vet them
is more thorough than any experience you
will ever have
and he said okay can you do it tomorrow
at 9 00 am with me
wow
so i i set up and i i interviewed this
potential client
and it got to feedback and i was
thinking in my head i was thinking
i don't really know this guy that well
if i give him if i give him feedback and
he doesn't like it he's not going to
work with me
but i thought you know what the right
thing to do here is to give him feedback
and i'm not saying i tore into him but i
gave him very honest objective feedback
that he could work on
and
i mean i think they i think they spent
about 200 grand with us last year
i love that and they probably did that
ended up being did they ended up being
the thing that like he picked up on that
was like unique or different probably
you even showing up to do it was
probably unique and different how many
people would then bottle it if he said
that yeah yeah he was like he was like
this is the most thorough
experience i've ever
had and he's like you know if
if you're gonna put every candidate
through this before they meet me
then you're my guy
you're gonna save me a lot of time
yeah
love that story thanks for sharing that
that's all right so okay cool so we've
got really doubling down on
relationships giving value
not being transactional
uh okay so let's just talk about a few
other things here then so you mentioned
then so it's definitely because this has
been annoyance that we picked up on but
you sort of said that the
in terms of just being a recruiter and
calling someone that's actually been
that's something that's sort of
perceived
better and differently yeah
in the u.s so that's fair to say
how about how about competition
how have you found that as you've been
growing the market into because
obviously we all you were here right
recruiting the uk is so [ __ ]
saturated yeah like how how did you find
that on that journey did you find that
you did end up competing with agencies a
lot or what was a competition
competition like yeah
i mean look
there's definitely there is the the
competition landscape is definitely less
saturated right like you just need to
look at the numbers to see that but it
doesn't mean there isn't any competition
like there's still absolutely
some really key players in the market
you know a couple of them are a couple
of them are us recruiters
that have been operating for a long time
a couple of them you know some of the
big british firms have moved out there
the
the difference the difference is
especially with a lot of the a lot of
the us recruiters that i see is they're
a bit like uh you know one-stop shop
right they do a lot of different things
whereas a lot of the british recruiters
that move over there um they they tend
to money focused and you know in in
niches
i mean i would say
every every person i work with
says to me you know i'm getting i'm
getting 10 12 calls a day from
recruiters or i'm getting 10 12 messages
a day from recruiters
because yeah maybe it's you know maybe
there's less recruiters here but you've
got you know hundreds of them sat in the
uk that work in the u.s market
okay so that's interesting
so what
so obviously you've ended up obviously
building traction building a reputation
yeah like what what do you think has
been like the number you've probably
spoken about but i just wanted to ask
and clarify like what has been the
number one thing do you think that has
really enabled you to like build a
reputation
i think
i think it really comes down to
being absolutely committed
to building great relationships with
great people
i i just don't think there's anything
that i don't think there's anything that
tops that
um and it's leveraging those too right
like i let people leverage my network as
much as i leverage theirs
so i'm happy to introduce
any of my customers to any of my
customers not expecting not maybe not
because they want like we get a lot of
like uh you know cyber vendors that want
to work with other cyber vendors
um unlike alliances and i very very
happily
will introduce them not to make any
money out of it but just because you
know i'm introducing two great people to
do you know great things
okay
nice let i've got some specific
questions for you okay
so i put um
a post out there and a couple of people
asked some really good questions i just
want to make sure we get them asked i
think this is a good moment because of
what we've been speaking about so i
guess to maybe wrap up then because
we've been speaking a bit about and
you've done a really good job of sharing
what you've learned and these things but
one of the questions was and i think a
lot of people are thinking this right is
like what would you say are the main
differences then in recruiting the us to
the uk
yeah so the point around point around
relationships i think you have to
you don't have to work as hard
to get someone on the phone but i think
you have to work a bit harder to really
build a you know a great relationship
with them
the second point is the point around uh
nuances with contracts
you want to you want to agree things up
front you want to get a contract you
know in place before you start working
on jobs
um it's a commitment thing it's also you
know contractually you're not as well
covered in the uk as you as you are you
know you know as you would be in the uk
i think those uh those for me are
probably the two the two main things
okay yeah nice
few other granular things
how um actually wait let me ask you this
first so how
how have your recruitment skills
developed since being in the us i like
that question
i would say
i've become
way more intense
in how i operate
i think
in the uk i was all right like i never
really achieved exceptional things in
the uk i never really like clicked into
into gear i think there was a lot of
potential there which hopefully is why
they moved me out here but i never
really had like an amazing quarter right
like i did all right
and when i moved to the us i just like
you know i was i was so
i mean this was up my chance right like
i had i was i
i wanted this so bad i still want it so
bad i want
i want us to build something exceptional
so much and i'm so driven to do that and
i think it's enabled me
to work with to work with more intensity
to work with more focus maybe a degree
of structure
and the other thing is i've really
transitioned
from
you know being a being an individual
contributor
to to leading people and that's been
that's been hard right like i'm sure i
hope my team will listen to this
um and there's been pain points right
it's really hard i was probably i was
probably a nightmare to begin with
yeah that's quite common
so what what's what's end up surprising
you the most then about the us that
maybe you weren't prepared for
um
[Music]
i think this might be a controversial
point
i don't necessarily think um
i think there's a lot of hype around it
well yes yeah i think people are like
you know you go to the u.s it's the
you know you you're gonna you know i
heard someone say once if you can build
200k in the uk then you can build a
million dollars in the us
yeah i've heard that before really i
don't necessarily agree with that
look the market the market is like if
you look at it statistically if you look
at the facts right then you have got
higher salaries you can probably get
higher fees in a lot of scenarios and
obviously that you know those two things
mean that that does set you up for a bit
bit more success in a way um but i think
it's got its other challenges you could
probably you can probably build 30 more
but depending on where you live it might
cost you 30 more to live there right
yeah so
i think i think yeah there's amazing
opportunity yeah you can you can do you
know you can achieve amazing amazing
things out here
i think
there is this there is this view that if
you go and do recruitment in america
then you're you know you're going to
make millions right and i don't
necessarily agree with that
yeah fairness no i appreciate you being
honest with that so couple of grand
other things then because there's i know
there's a few more things you want to
talk about but i'm actually really keen
to get your take on your experience of
actually josh the human being taking his
life to the us because i think that's
something that's really important for
people to consider and factor as well
so just couple of granular things i know
people always want to want to know right
so first one is and we don't maybe don't
have to go into as much detail but like
what what does locker i think again
people interested in this what does like
a typical what's the average interview
process look like in the u.s is it
shorter is it the same sort of thing i
know it depends on role but all in all
like is it a bit more of a quicker
turnaround yeah
probably not it's probably exactly the
same to be honest i mean
i used to i used to recruit contracts in
the uk
um i recruit perm now so i've not really
done perm before and some people i knew
in perm i'd say it's probably about the
same on average
also our permanent candidates actually
available more quickly do they all have
one week notice periods is that a thing
as well the yeah the average the average
notice period is two weeks
two weeks yeah
and that's definitely the case that
you've experienced yeah yeah i would say
99 of people we've placed have been on
two week notice periods
okay cool
a bit more candidate stuff then so like
interesting one because i've spoke to a
few people about this before and this
was actually more from an internal angle
but like from your perspective to our
candidates in the us
do you think uh the question was like
how do people in the u.s put more
emphasis on like the company benefits
uh i can't is it like the 401k i don't
know what
salary
i think
to be honest i think it's pretty
holistic like
you know
healthcare obviously is like quite a big
thing because unlike the uk we don't
have the nhs in the us um you don't have
public health care so i think health
care is a big thing yeah 401 k is a big
thing i think broadly speaking though
like people always look quite
holistically at the package um
quite a pragmatic way to look at it
but yeah i'd say you know
you definitely you know talk about these
things but there is there is i guess a
classic there's there's an expectation
that like the healthcare will be broadly
in line with what the market covers
401k would be broadly alarming the
market and anything above that is a
bonus anything down from that you
probably want to flag early on
how have you found covert impact the
remoteness that companies are willing to
hire from
because obviously america's so big
yeah so like so like because that and
has has it ended up open like have you
ended up because i guess yeah i have now
i guess it depends what market you're in
but is it really ended up sort of
opening up talent pools where people
may not have been able to commute in
previously i don't know how's that yeah
was that landscape look like definitely
i think
i think you know with
a lot of the roles that we recruited
anyway were you know a lot of it was
moving towards remote but i would say a
ton more of it is now i mean the us's
you know you frequently hear people talk
about you know well it's easy just to
sort of hop on a plane right like a lot
of people are quite used to doing one or
two you know a lot of professional
people are quite used in one or two
domestic flights a week
really yeah yeah i remember like early
on like people say you know when we're
setting the business up they're like oh
yeah get used to sort of like you know
hopping all over the place going to new
york for a meeting going to san
francisco for a meeting and stuff like
that i mean that hasn't really
materialized because of covered and
because there's one or two conferences a
year which we can go to and kind of see
most of our most of our customers
um
but yeah that's probably the biggest
shift is i think people definitely
aren't traveling as much as they did a
couple of years ago
yeah that's interesting and then one
that obviously people always hear about
so you've spoken about higher salaries
which come in like bigger
fees
but like what about you don't have to
give me like the average at stanton
house but like has
had like what what's the sort of typical
percentage that you end up working with
customers on
is it ended up being high because people
said like 30 in the us
like what's ended up being what's quite
normal
i mean i think
i think the you know you get you get
companies a bit like the uk right you
get companies like that are i guess the
bottom rate that you kind of see
companies go right is this or nothing
which is a bit like resonates with my
experience in the uk is probably 20
whereas in the uk say that's 15 right
but you might get like a big account um
there are definitely instances where you
can get
um
you know
28 to 32 which is pretty decent um i
heard about someone getting 40 once i
don't know if that's a little bit
unethical
um depends what they have
what's like what's like the average that
you're aiming with your team that you
feel is
like achievable like if you were to save
your team right by the end of the year i
really want us to be aiming for our
average fee percentage to be and around
this i think somewhere you know 28 30
i'd be really happy with i'm confident
that the
that what we provide that provides great
value for for our customers too and
means that i can sleep easy at night
knowing that our customers are getting
great value i never want anyone to be
getting ripped off by it right
uh yeah for sure especially because it's
quite a vulnerable thing you know you're
signing a contract
with a recruiter you've never worked
with before that's quite an interesting
point
whereas in the uk you typically give
them give them the you know you bring
the product to them and then you sign
the contract in a lot of scenarios but
they're signing that before yeah yeah
so when you're when you're agreeing
you know you're agreeing a rate before
you've delivered anything
it's quite an interesting thing to
navigate because there's no
there's no product to go well you know
here's here's proof of the value right
yeah that is interesting so is that when
you then had to double down on obviously
showcasing the way you work experience
those things yeah i mean one of the one
of the big things i do is i'll just i'll
just send a list of people that they can
call so i'll be like right any of these
10 people
here are their email addresses and phone
numbers they will act as a reference for
us
yeah
so before before i ask you about your
own personal journey then like
she's spoken about a few different
things i know this will be really
helpful for people but like
what if you were to start all over again
how would you do it differently
i think
i don't know whether i would do anything
differently
okay i think i learned i think i learned
so much doing it the way i did it
and
you know maybe i would have okay here's
one i think my my
business development strategy was
probably a little bit like too many eggs
in one basket to start with i don't
think i did enough um
sort of spec in
and stuff like that and i mostly focus
on building building senior
relationships which is kind of naturally
what i'm good at
so i think i could have you know i was i
was uncomfortable
in a new market in a new city and i
think i probably
was a little bit a little bit i wanted
to stay in my comfort zone to a degree
with the way that i worked like i wanted
to you know i i
i was attracted to working in the way
that i felt was best for me whereas
actually
you know my colleague james he you know
got there and started doing a lot more
spec in and i think he had a few sort of
earlier wins and it probably put his
market a few months ahead of mine
yeah fair
so what so people in the thick of it now
right now then or on the journey like or
people that may be at the very beginning
of the journey like what
what would your advice be to them to
sort of wrap this all up
i would say
reach out to loads of people
and ask for a ton of advice right and
and put it into put it into action
i would say keep your keep your strategy
quite broad like you know decide on work
out what your operating model is really
quickly
i think i'm not trying to over
complicate recruitment
but i think when you're building a
market you need to fundamentally
understand what are the things that you
need to do
on a weekly basis that are going to get
you to where you are right because when
you're sat in a mature uk business
you've got people who are telling you
what that is when you're building a new
market in a new country
you're kind of in the driving seat on
that
so it's something i always push myself
on and when we expand into new markets
it's a big focus is what are the you
know three things the five things that
you need to do on a weekly basis to say
john i've had a great week i'm going in
the right direction yeah well and we'll
just give an example of one of those
things is it like
uh have x number of candidate regis per
week those types of things spot on so
like mine would have been like get us
back out every weekend every week
suspect becca's senior person out every
week um meet three senior people line up
four senior meetings you know stuff like
that it's the
it's about measuring that meaningful
input so that you can really benchmark
whether or not you're on track yeah and
if yeah you're yeah because then you can
look at leading indicators that you are
yeah exactly so
so as we come to the end here like last
five minutes or so i want to make sure i
ask you like
because i i think whenever i speak to
people that have made the move i think
sometimes this can be overlooked
so like what
what did i guess what was
maybe challenging for you personally
when you're first obviously it helped
that you were with two other guys yeah
then if you live together or whatever
but like what like personally what was
that journey like for you in terms of
like actually building social circles
there all those types of things like the
stuff that yeah isn't work right because
you're not you're not [ __ ] working 24
hours like you're living in chicago so
like what was that actually like well
that's one of the hardest things right
is to not work 24 hours because you've
just moved somewhere to build a business
and you don't know that many people
it's really really easy
to just like be plugged in all the time
and i was definitely a bit like that um
look i mean i was
i'll say this and my friends and family
know this i was really ready for the
move
like i personally as soon as i got there
i was like i feel happy i didn't know i
was a bit miserable in the uk like i
don't know what it was it was like
something clicked in me so i was really
ready for it but look it's really
vulnerable um
[Music]
it feels like it feels like you're on
holiday for you on a vacation for the
first few months and that is a bit
mental because it means that you eat out
every night you spend loads of money um
big advice that i'll give to anyone
moving to the states move here with a
load of money saved up i didn't
and i ran dry pretty quickly
yeah
but yeah you just you just live like
you're on holiday you live you know and
it's it's great fun and the first time i
didn't it didn't really resonate with me
until the first time i went home you
know i went i went i flew back for
christmas i moved end of october so i
went back for christmas and when i left
my family after christmas that's when
it's suddenly like i sat on the plane i
was like
oh i live somewhere else like that's the
moment that yeah it really really hit me
whereas before the previous couple of
months i was like this is amazing i'm on
holiday right
yeah
yeah i think you know put yourself out
there um i went on a lot of mandates um
you know i'd like yeah i you know i
don't know like maybe i'll be at a bar
or something and you know you get
chatting having a laugh and i'll go look
i promise i'm not coming on to you but
do you want to ever go for a beer and i
make
friends
by doing stuff like that like i just
think you need to it's quite a weird
thing to make friends as an adult right
yeah yeah as you get older yeah because
you by then you sort of got yourself
called friends haven't you yeah and you
typically was it is there like is it
obviously you're in chicago is there an
ex back um expat culture or like
community there or
yeah there's a there's a there's a
facebook page called brits in chicago
which is really there's probably one for
every state to be fair yeah yeah there
probably is which is mostly like
middle-aged people who live in like
right in the suburbs right like um but
you do find you do find like there's
probably now
a group of like you know we've got a
brits in chicago whatsapp group and
there's probably 20 30 of us something
like that so we've built up quite a good
little how did you end up meeting each
other just on like seeing each other on
like linkedin and stuff like that yeah
face on that facebook page brits in
chicago we found a couple of people um
found people um you know just going down
to like the irish bars like when the
euros was on you know you'd see someone
sat by yourself there's a lad that moved
it last year that we saw sat by himself
at the euros bless him
i think the cool thing about that is you
eventually got something in common yeah
because you you've moved your like life
over there so like you've instantly got
common ground of like how have you found
it what like what's been the weirdest
thing so far
what visa are you on you know i mean all
that so like
yeah that's cool so overall then i guess
i'm sure there's been some challenging
times but overall it's been like a
really it seemed like a real sort of you
as a human being like a growth just you
you've really grown as a person which is
really cool
yeah i love that
josh
absolute pleasure thank you so much for
sharing thanks for being so honest
transparent i know that would be really
helpful for people and i know that
you're someone that's always keen to
help so if if anyone wants um yeah more
uh advice or thoughts then definitely
make sure you connect with josh on
linkedin but yeah josh really excited to
see where you take the business in the
next couple years so thanks so much for
for joining me cool thanks asian